hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about my eighth Kum Joe so
my eighth Kum Joe is very similar to
cyos Sensei fourth Kum Joe um it's
getting into the series that in my
opinion is less likely to come off and
would only come off more in kind of a
panic state or in a state where you
could kind of mess around because you're
you're better than them right so so it's
like this lower percentage stuff in my
opinion so I'm gonna get Josh over here
and we're going to go to work Josh
all right so let's talk about my eighth
Kum Joe which is cyto sense's fourth Kum
Jo okay so uh in this series these next
two we're going to be talking about
grabbing the Joe this way which is for
the Kishi ski right so the choku ski
down here the Kishi SK up here um we'll
talk about why it's called kisi in the
Sabuy video when we make the saaby video
but I'm going to grab up here now if you
think about it
in some ways it's kind of easier to grab
the stick this way um if I hit it and it
came back this would be easier to grab
and if I just reached out and this is
easier because I don't have to sink down
to get it and when I pull it back this
way I really specifically have to try to
bring it to this hand so if I was going
to freak out this kind of freak out
might be more common um I think it is
from my own experience maybe that's true
or not for you but it is definitely a
way that it might come back to grab the
hand okay so in this we're going to be
in the configuration we've seen ever
since
uh four started uh my fourth Kum Joe
which is Josh is in ski Kamai in his
range and I'm in Joe Kamai and
unprepared situation at that range when
Josh comes in for the ski I'm going to
grab on top and I'm going to draw up
here to Banji no Kamai now I'm trying to
shoot back far and I didn't jump back as
far as I normally would because uh the
camera but uh I'm trying to hop back
really far I want to hop back far enough
that if he came in for a second ski it
wouldn't work okay now we know from the
forms then that what Josh should do is
go jodan guch but if you notice what I
did I came into a defended position for
jodan guch which is fantastic so if I'm
mentally ahead enough to realize that
I'm not in a dangered position and he
transitions to jodu I can do this which
I pull myself back even further and I
whack him in the hand when that's going
on right so this is a clever tactical
idea in my opinion that's like well I
made the best out of a kind of crummy
situation in my opinion this position's
harder to work from but I me made it
work for me so when joshh comes in and I
hop back like this I'm already defended
against what Josh is going to do and so
if Josh tries to do what the forms have
been teaching us to do as he goes to do
that I can step back and I can pop that
hand and and hopefully disable it and
then we can deal with that okay however
Josh is going to see that I'm doing that
and he's going to use his own banin no
Kamai so as he comes in here he starts
to do that and just as he starts to do
it he sees me coming in and he defends
that with with Banji noai so he just
turns his Jordan guch into a ban no
Kamai boom and he's safe now after I
swing through there will be a time that
I'm a little bit vulnerable that I'm
here like this so what Josh's going to
do is step to the backside and give me a
Thrust bang that's what he's looking for
so as he goes to do that I step away
from that and I thrust him Center chest
right so uh I'm turning what should be a
kind of bad position this into just uh a
High Ski Joni so we're here as Josh
comes in I hop back like this as Josh
comes in I hop back he defends that he
comes for me I step up and I thrust so
um the big thing we're seeing there is
that Outreach Outreach tactic which I
think is a nice tactic when they're
trying to run you down that's a huge
backwards movement so not only can I hop
back big this way but I can take a full
aumi AI back this way which really puts
me away from the danger zone so it's
really nice and I'm using my Tomo uch my
longest possible strike in order to deal
with that extra range advantage means I
can still hit Josh can't hit me so again
we're seeing this idea in the last form
we kind of saw this idea that Kates can
beat kinis right now the problem with
the Kates is they tend to be less
controlling because there's only one
hand on this long stick so hard to deal
with that and so at the end of that we
see a way that I could manage if I use a
Tomo uch to come back and still still go
to work so form's pretty straightforward
in my opinion um I put it towards the
end because I don't think there's a
whole lot of amazing information in this
um although there's a great tactic and a
great idea and so it's still one of the
forms because I think there's cool stuff
in it um but that's the my basic take on
that uh and this is my eighth Kum Joe
I'm Christopher H it's Joshua my salon
MCD is behind that camera right there
and we'll see you in the next video